Donald Trump took time out of
his busy schedule a-tweetin' on
the crapper to take over the one
place even more bat-shit crazy
than him...
Japanese wrestling!
(laughter)
That's, uh, definitely him.
I don't...
DDT pro wrestling just unveiled
their new leader, Donald Trump,
who they say evolved out of a
regular Japanese wrestler,
quote, "like a Pokémon." And...
(laughter)
...judging by this picture,
I'm assuming it was Bulbasaur.
(laughter)
Good, you guys are still
playing.
This Trump... this Trump wasted
no time establishing his
policies on gay rights by
announcing a, quote, "anal
explosion death match" between
the world's strongest gay
wrestler... and the world's
strongest penis fighter.
And unlike some Donald Trumps I
could name, this one followed
through on his promises.
(audience groans, laughter,
shouting)
Under Trumpcare, that's a
prostate exam.
(laughter)
(applause, whooping)
It kind of... I also...
Doesn't it... doesn't it also
look like this truck is going,
"I've driven into them.
Pardon me. I'll just... be...
backing out."
(imitating backup beeping)
Uh, what are some other Japanese
wrestling matches Trump will
order?
Brian.
>> Uh, tiny thumb wrestling.
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points!
Uh, Stephanie.
>> Slam them by the pussy.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Very good. Very good.
(applause)
Uh, Sasheer.
>> Father-daughter mud
wrestling.
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points!
Perfect!
(laughter, whooping, applause)
Very good, Sasheer. Thank you.
(like Trump): I mean, the mud's
optional, you know, the mud's
optional.
We could have it, we could not
have it.